if you make all of your adult decisions
with your feelings you are by definition
a child mhm and so when you purchase
something that you can't afford with
money that you don't have to impress
people you don't even really like at 21%
on subprime and then you get delinquent
on the payment yeah
$1,142 car payment M then you become a
statistic and then people like Forbes
make fun of your entire generation the
problem is Dave is if you're always
pointing to the the problem out there
that's the reason it's the the the
dealership it's the interest rates it's
inflation it's supply chain if you're
always pointing to something out there
for your own behavior you'll never be
able to fix it you'll never be able to
fix it